[Musik]
venedig willkommen in der stadt von geld
und geist
hierhin haben kaufleute schon vor
tausend jahren wertvolle waren
importiert und von hier aus exportierten
kreuzritter den christen glauben
hier treffe ich auf den cvp präsidenten
gerhard pfister der sich einen
wochenendausflug könnt
[Musik]
den christdemokraten frage ich wie seine
rate spar und finanzpolitik mit
christlicher barmherzigkeit
zusammenpasst
[Musik]
es ist es ist wichtig dass das man
verantwortungsvolle finanzpolitik machen
um starke start ist immer noch das
höchste zahl von verantwortungsloser ist
eingetreten
verantwortungslose finanzpolitik gemacht
haben es gar nicht einfach es geht um
die schwächsten sportwoche gesunden
finanzhaushalt unabdingbare
voraussetzung dass der schwächste im
inland gab
diese filmstar versuch einen schweizer
politiker zu erklären der für viele
seiner kollegen auch nach jahrelanger
zusammenarbeit nicht fassbar ist
[Musik]
herbst 2001 kanton zug um kartons
parlament feuert der amok laibacher 88
schüsse auf politikerinnen und politiker
14 menschen bleiben tot liegen
einige hatten an diesem tag glück cvp
kantonsrat gerd vista zum beispiel
überlebt das attentat völlig unverletzt
sein sitznachbar stirbt
[Musik]
der glaube mit kumpel
ich glaube machte ein
für mich macht eigentlich sache schwerer
als das mich da wenn der glaube stellt
ein großer große frage wo vielleicht
hätten wir jetzt keinen spezifischen
glauben aber sie will will nach seinen
ereignis was überwiegt sind ja schon
zweifel sind verflogen
zwiebel warum warum hat man selber
überlebt und der sitze nachbau eine
familien beste freunde
romero findet sich auch keine
vernünftige antwort
und auf die frage hilft der glaube er
hat mir jetzt persönlich glaube jetzt
also waren sie in die kurve
der ab vista unterwegs seiner heimat der
innerschweiz
hier ist vista verwurzelt hier ist er
gereicht worden
sein vater sein großvater katholisch
konservative politiker seine mutter
gestorben als er erst acht war
ich glaube also hinter dieser forschung
ja ich habe schon philosophie studiert
und philosophie ist eher rationale
herausforderer von glaube und
für mich persönlich glaube das nicht
geht das widersprüche und ich finde die
videos kosmos auto das laut agof ist
aber nicht widersprüchlich und wer seid
ihr seid der visit wahrheit und er wisse
ganz genau
wir sind die wahl zu und her gehen
[Musik]
aber das finde er macht es war
der philosoph esther singt ein loblied
auf den zweifeln der politiker pfister
aber gibt sich immer zu 100 prozent
überzeugt gott rückkehr wie wir jetzt
erfahren
[Musik]
das ist für mich dass ich eigentlich nur
sie und jetzt muss man eigentlich klar
sie also ich halte ich für mich selber
weiß mit es aber trocken
es gibt denn es geht dem satz ich glaube
das ist formal berg wo es immer wieder
gern meint robert gates oder marc sauter
wenn er muss die innere parteimitglied
sie dann wäre es in der partei verdient
sich also in der nacht hat pfister ist
also mitglied der cvp schon seit 1984
und jetzt halt stirn präsident hat sich
der ehemalige rechtsausleger auch selbst
ein bisschen eingemietet er ist
zugänglicher geworden als präsident er
ist glaubwürdig er denkt differenziert
er macht als die cvp
ich bin sehr zufrieden ich bin einfach
sauer um ihn als präsidenten
ja der piste ausgabe 2017 ist akzeptiert
bei seinem cvp landauf landab
er fühlt sich wohl als chef ist in
seinem element
ich gebe zu ich habe freude an der musik
von morgen felix aber leistet und auf
ihre führungsposition ist in der
machtposition ist das ist ja das war ich
immer schlimmer kriegt man nirgendwo
ohne dass es kühl halten müssen wir
seinen bringen
oder dass ich es mache keinen sinn dass
wir zum einkommen geboren oder bestimmt
ist
könnte sie also dass man die vielleicht
eine andere entscheidung führe gern ich
schade dass in dem sinne macht der news
die macht fister liebt sie und die macht
die liebt einen strategen wie ihn sehr
gute strategie
unglaublich starker analytiker aber ich
habe sie ihre sorgfältige dank
interfracht als seine eigene
entscheidung und als zwischen tore 12
doch das aber das macht ihn sehr
menschlich telefon also mein job ist
überhaupt bis mimose aufzeichnet wir
werden natürlich gewinne er mit seiner
entscheidung
und dann darf ich menschlich dass wenn
es denn nicht schafft das was ringo
bedeckt hält
in der cvp bundeshausfraktion ist er der
chef filippo lombardi
hier ist piste einer unter gleichen und
bringt mit seinen vorstellungen lange
nicht immer durch das macht die muffelig
erteilt gegen parteikollegen hart aus
geht manchmal zu weit
ja ja das dass das ist mir weismachen
eine bewusste nach 1 1 mio starlight
sich eine doppelstunde aber dass ich sie
wollen nicht mehr viel zeit wird der
zweite deutsche liga eine andere tonlage
und dann hätte vielleicht mehr auf das
weiterkommen
pfister teil scharf aus zb in diesen
brief an saf den er unter anderem auch
an mich adressiert hat absage von
auftritten bei sf weil vista mit einem
entscheid der arena redaktion nicht
einverstanden war
er orte abneigung gegen die cvp stehe er
für diesen film und andere sendungen
nicht zur verfügung
daran gehalten hat er sich zum glück
nicht
[Musik]
dass ich jetzt trotz länder wie das hat
einfach die menschen
man muss sich dann irgendwann krank
ja ich mache aus bad eilsen darf
verpflichtet der altstadt und das ist
eine entwicklung über mini kann da nie
wieder restaurant isst man ist nie
wieder es knallhart im auftritt aber im
kern doch ein zauderer wie bei der
wertedebatte dir provokant anstieß aber
einschlafen ließ trotz seinen scharfen
verstand scheint vista immer mal wieder
aus dem takt zu geraten
[Musik]
aber ich bin nicht schnell und scharf
oder das ist das ist schon so dass ich
sowieso nicht und dazu dienen den
erfordert jetzt sehr politisch aber wer
sich wirklich also an selbiger kühl
dahinter dahinter
tanz negieren es ist männlich findet
europas lotz ihnen tue man einfach mal
eine position zu markieren oder wollen
wir dann wieder stark spürt und warum
deine reaktion gespürt ich glaube da
muss man meinen aber ich gebe zu es ist
auch darüber würden würde ich anders
formen
kalkül also ein wetteifern um macht und
einfluss im bundeshaus wo ränkespiele
und geheime absprachen stets in der luft
liegen wo ein abkommen heute beschlossen
und morgen geschossen wird hier kann
fester politik als großes spiel
betreiben
denn fester liebt den wettbewerb ist
ehrgeizig will sich im kampf um macht
durchsetzen bilanz sieger vom parkett
gehen
das klappt nicht immer
oberägeri kanton zug hier ist er jetzt
unterwegs zu jenem flecken erde auf dem
seine familie über drei generationen
gewirkt hat heimisch war und den er
aufgibt hero pfister einst aufwuchs wird
jetzt alles abgerissen
sein großvater hatte das schule internat
pfister hoch über ihre gegründet sein
vater führte es weiter pfister musste
schließen eine dynastie endete vista
wurde vom schulleiter zum
nachlassverwalter gefühle zwei meter
steht als komisch vor dem haus ab gegner
großer abstand ist noch vollständig ich
bin doch jedes zimmer hat ein abstieg
nachmittags insofern es komisch vor aber
vor allem im geistigen haus sehen immer
noch wo was gestanden ist wohl was sie
ist
200 schüler besuchten jedes gen oder die
sekundarschule der großvater kaufte der
1920 ein stück land das sich jetzt
vergolden lässt
pfister übernahm vom vater in den 90er
jahren die zwar exquisite lage dies
räumliche erweiterung aber kaum noch zu
und weil der kinderlose pfister auch
keine nachfolgeregelung sagt schlosser
die schule mangels zukunftsperspektive
dass er das werk seiner väter aufgabe
habe er heute überwunden und
rückversicherung sehe damit wir
überhaupt haben könne bildungsstätte für
ihre und nur schock sie dass ich das
realisieren für dazu dass ich in neuheim
eine andere tagesschule überhaupt wieder
mit investitionen aufbauen das sagen
dass es ist ein wandel
man muss also unternehmer der
unterschiedlichen gegebenheiten abwasser
mit perfect marktgerechter aussicht über
dem see sind und 22 eigentumswohnungen
im bau an deren gewinn pfister und seine
geschwister beteiligt werden
750.000 franken aus dem boden verkauf
hatte nach eigener angabe bereits
investiert in eine neue schule
hier neuheim ebenfalls kanton zug
betreibt piste seine neue schule sein
investment eine tagesschule mit
schachspielen den kindern aus eher
besseren häusern kostet doch der monat
rund 2500 franken pro kind
die elemente sei tatsächlich auf eine
internationale kundschaft ausgerichtet
nicht aber auf elitäres denken dass
jedes kind sind die stärken unserer fans
und das tool die stärken und hinterland
sehr stark förderer militär kamen durch
aussagen wie ist natürlich eine
privatschule modell alles zahlen wo die
öffentliche schule natürlich gut ist wie
immer wie die schweiz
diese ungerechtigkeit wenn mein kind in
den privaten kindergarten der zukunft
[Musik]
kombiniert man den humanistisch
gebildeten christa mit dem harten
finanzpolitiker aus dem kanton zug dann
kommt der schul unternehmer pfister
heraus wenn sie unternehmerisch tätig
sind im bildungsbereich der münchner
messe und ich glaube medaille sind also
dass das familienform unabhängig davon
wie sie sind dass man das kindeswohl es
zentrum steht und das machen wir doch
eigentlich familienform unabhängig davon
wie sich irgendwas muss ich jetzt wieder
drunter vorstellen
ich glaube sicher realität dass
verschiedene lebensmodell und der ehe
modelle und familienmodell da sind aber
wichtig ist klar aufgabe von der schule
des kindes worden ist
hartmut beurteilen wir die einzelnen
themen arbeit fordert er sich persönlich
danken und was ich von der schlappe mit
maxime für alles
eigenständig nachdenken beflügelt und
ermöglicht erst den wert der schöpfung
zu erkennen
das individuum muss sich selber finden
und vor gott ein besserer mensch zu
werden
dieser humanistischen tradition fühlt
sich pfister als studierter philosoph
verpflichtet und engagiert sich im
internat montana auf dem zugerberg als
verwaltungsrat
händen stadt einige beispiele stadt
vorbilder bildung statt ikonen lange
jahre ist vista philosophielehrer ein
spannender und engagierter noch dazu
sagen jene die ihn damals erlebten
natürlich als lehrer ist die versuchung
groß schülern das eigene menschenbild
aufzudrücken sie die eine wahrheit zu
lehrern sowie man sind der politik
machen muss aber wo gott hockt sagt
pfister bisher er weder als politiker
noch hbrs als lehrer gewusst
ich habe mich bemüht ihnen keine
mannschaft als fix dass man schon
mitbringen will ich glaube das muss
jeder für sich selbst finden und sich
keine machen
mir ist wichtig dass jeder sie niemeyer
und die auch einen vertreter aber muss
argument da höre ich sie denn die
zughalte gelungen als lehrer und sie
kritisiert ich glaube ja ich glaube ja
dass ist das ist man wirklich immer dass
alle gags sie wählen
es ist wichtig dass schüler wissen ist
staunen und das system eigentlich keine
aber gut die guten diskussionen starte
ich will schon in der schule
die politik kann ich keine freude an
andere meinungen aus also am einigen
weil die griechen sind wir dann geht die
diskussion den dialog und den operativen
unbedingt mit ihnen die politik ja in
der politik sind sie natürlich gefordert
dass man für den start wo man selber
vertreter sich genauso wichtig dass man
sich bewusst ist dass eine sitte von der
wahrheit das mini persönliche wahrheit
dass meine persönliche überzeugung und
das muss keineswegs die einzig richtige
sie soll man es geht sehr viele andere
über zügige hauptsache ich mache sie
begründet das ist natürlich sehr sehr
wichtig
[Musik]
der wettstreit der argumente schärft das
denken diesen leitsatz nehme ich mit
zurück nach venedig der stadt im wasser
welche pfister immer wieder besucht um
abzuschalten und auszuruhen
hier in oberitalien oder humanismus
seinen ursprung hat und von wo aus er
ganz europa eroberte hier lerne ich
jenen menschen kennen der piste am
besten beurteilen kann
franziska seine frau seit bald 23 jahren
sie studierte kunstgeschichte und
italienisch und gemeinsam teilen sie die
liebe zum land der kunst und des kreuzes
was sagt sie über priester ist er so
hart wie er sich im politischen alltag
oft gibt kritisiert sie ihn
ich probiere das spiel gesehen und ich
komisch finden oder ist ob formuliert
oder so wieder zu kritik von frau hat
bist du anders stolz auf kritik
also es ist es ich mir meine sie kennt
mich am besten oder und sie weiß zwar
schon am besten und unter beweis dass
kritik vor ihrer für mich ja mit winter
bringt also das ist schon wichtig damit
sie aber auch ein mörder nach den
schwächen obwohl x box integriert über
den aus politiker zeit des rennens über
die hausbewohner mannschaft vielleicht
ja schon mit dem gedanken hier zusammen
sind in der öffentlichkeit muss er eine
steuer muss paroli bieten muss schnell
sie muss aguirre
und ja das wusste ich nur sagen das
spiel wo man gewisse kraft und hat eben
ein kompromissloser einfach noch ist das
spiel wohl nur zehn personen sprich das
ist die grenze zu bringen ganz klar aber
die aber nichts mit privatpersonen und
ich bin auf alles andere als konservativ
aber ich einfach von der definition und
was sagt man heute im bereich
aber das schließt das schließt liberale
ideen
das ist genau das ist meine repariert
und wo viele leute machen oder weniger
beurteilung von mir trotz von kann ich
mein gerät unterstützt mini liberalität
[Musik]
wenn der zweifel nagte ist ein art
geäußerten standpunkt ein notausgang
notwehr gegen das innere zögern und
gegen den anspruch auf klarheit von
außen pfister der knallharte zweifler in
der mitte redet klartext und wird gehört
und solange man über ihn und damit die
cvp spricht bleibt die partei ein faktor
im spiel um macht und einfluss
[Musik]